well welcome back to another edition of
down the middle
i recently had the pleasure of
interviewing charlie plosser he was kind
of my first former fed insider if you
will
uh that i've been able to interview but
today we have with us
joseph wang i've been following him on
on twitter at fed guy 12 saying to
myself who is this guy who understands
the plumbing of the financial system so
well well it turns out that that mr wang
is the author of central banking 101
which i highly recommend we all read
because the plumbing has become the
mechanics of the financial system have
become so critical
he was for five years a senior trader on
the open markets desk at the federal
reserve bank of new york where he
executed open market operations and
studied the inner workings of the
financial system prior to that he worked
at standard poor's and practiced law
you've got all kinds of education going
on here you've got a ba from
northwestern an ms from oxford
university and a jd from columbia law
school we're both columbia alma maters
and um and we both we both wrote books
about the fed here's fed up an insider's
take on why the federal reservist is bad
for america your title's much kinder
uh than mine um but but tell me what
what were these last five years like
before you left in june of 2021
well first of all daniel i want to thank
you for coming for inviting on to your
show i really love your show and i loved
your book too it was just a great read
and i recommend it to anyone who wants
to learn more about how the fed is
especially about the people behind the
fed
and so i worked on the open markets desk
for the last five years and it was a
really good learning experience when
you're on the open market set you're
kind of basically in one of the centers
of the financial world um the open
market desk is basically at the fed's
trading desk and so it's the trading
desk that conducts qe and it's a trading
desk that does all the market
intelligence for the fed so you have
connections you have contacts throughout
the financial world you get to talk to
primary dealers the biggest hedge funds
mutual funds money market funds banks so
it's a really good learning experience
you you can really get kind of a behind
the current look as to what people are
thinking and what's going
and on top of that of course the fed has
just
reams and reams of confidential data um
just regulatory data and just things
that unless you work there you wouldn't
be able to see so you can really put
together a very good holistic view of
what's going on in the financial system
and also how the mechanics of it work
and so um that's basically what i
specialize i was on the money markets
there and so i basically studied the
plumbing of the financial system
and it was an exciting time to be on i
mean through the crisis the repo crisis
and of course the covet pandemic panic
well uh so i'll give you a tiny bit of
background on on on how unorthodox it
was to work for richard fisher so uh he
established his own markets desk at the
dallas fed so i did kind of what you
before every fomc i would travel to new
york
and it was so fascinating that being a
fed insider
you it was it was akin to being a priest
it didn't matter who you were speaking
to and in what capacity whether they
were on the buy side or the sell side
they would they would give you their
confession they would give you all the
data and information and intelligence
that you ever asked for just by virtue
of you working at the fed did you have
that same sensation
absolutely absolutely and um i i i know
that you were ahead of everyone in
calling what was happening in the
residential real estate market back then
and so that was awesome um
being at the fed every time you every
person you talk to they just assume that
the competition is confidential and and
like you said it's it's like a priestly
confession so they'll tell you what
they're thinking what they're doing and
why and it's really eye-opening because
you get that perspective from basically
all the major market players and no one
else has that no one in the entire world
so
it is a very i think very privileged
position
so um
when i was at the fed i was really good
friends with zoltan pozar and uh and he
and i have stayed in contact uh over the
years i i'm curious uh
when when when zoltan was at the fed
there was a map of the financial system
kind of in the middle of that um
kind of in the middle of that
was the
central clearing of what was the repo
market basically
and you after that
he
he said that
that the map that was flat had turned
into an atlas
and that the plumbing of the financial
system had undergone
serious changes in the aftermath of of
the great financial crisis
and the way it operated and and the
players
operating
in it uh had also changed and this is
really dry arcane stuff but
kind of
at the highest level
why is it important to understand
the inner workings of of the financial
system
so the financial system is kind of like
the plumbing right i mean
you when it works no one notices
everything you just assume it to work
but when it doesn't work then things can
really blow up so at a very fundamental
level
throughout the financial system the way
that these financial players work is
they have short-term liabilities and
longer-term assets right so they assume
that they can always roll over their
short-term liabilities right that's how
a bank works in terms of deposit and
let's say loan assets that's how a
dealer works in terms of repo loans and
holding treasuries that's how money
market fund works in terms of having
let's say money market fund shares and
then let's say trevory bills on one side
and being able to roll those loans over
every day is basically dependent upon
the plumbing the system being able to
have uh short-term loans that roll over
every day the second that doesn't work
then
everything kind of
breaks in a sense because in order to
meet uh you you're going to have to sell
assets for example to repay your loans
because you can't roll over them anymore
and when a lot of people do that then
asset prices start crashing and then
maybe more people have to sell assets
get margin calls and so everything blows
up
and um that's kind of why it's really
unders important to understand the
plumbing because it's kind of
basically the whole system is based upon
these short-term loans that
that are assumed to work and usually
they always do i mean i think in
september a couple years ago that it did
have some kind of
uh problem and during the financial
crisis it did as well
but
usually though it works fine but when it
doesn't uh bad things happen
well we i mean we we can go all the way
back to bear stearns and yeah that was
your absolute classic textbook example
if you can explain kind of what happened
at bear stearns just as kind of a primer
of what happens when
you can't roll those
those funds over
right so bear stearns had bear cerns as
a big dealer back then right and they
had and not just bear certain
to begin with later lehman as well they
were basically a dealer and the dealers
functioned by having um longer term
assets and borrowing overnight in the
repo market and at those times it was
treasuries and it was mortgage related
assets right so what would happen is
that if you were a money market fund
investor you had a bunch of cash and you
would invest it overnight kind of like
um you and me putting money in the bank
on a in a checking account
except that
when you invest when you lend your money
to a dealer you're lending it on an
overnight basis and you get collateral
as a security right and back then that
was mortgage-related assets
now
the way that you the way that you make
money as a dealer well there's a lot of
ways but one of them is that you could
for example
fund these assets in the overnight
market and then you wait for someone to
sell wait for someone who wants to buy
them right so you're holding inventory
or maybe you try to collect a little bit
of that roll
um for example you
could have a let's say slightly
longer-term asset yielding like five
percent and you keep borrowing at two
percent so earning that two three
percent coupon uh three percent interest
rate differential
and this all works as long as you can
continue to get funded as long as people
continue to lend you money on a
short-term basis
when people stop doing that though then
well
you bought all this you borrowed all
this money to buy these assets and now
you have to pay pay that money back then
right so how do you do that well then
you have to steal your assets
and that works fine if the markets are
liquid but if markets are not liquid
then then when you sell that asset you
lose a lot of money
and when you lose a lot of money then
you know people start panicking and then
more people don't want to lend you money
then you have to sell even more assets
and what that happens though is that the
entire financial markets kind of creator
then everyone else is kind of
having some problems on their asset side
and maybe
they're getting margin calls and maybe
people don't want to lend them money
anymore so you kind of have this
avalanche of um
selling that you get selling
that ultimately turns into a crash and
that's kind of what happened back then
in bear stearns and lehman brothers
people were not sure whether or not the
dealers were solvent because they had
some assets on their balance sheet that
were
you know mortgage related assets that
people were worried about
yeah i mean i mean we don't talk about
counterparty risk anymore but we sure
did back then i mean it was a big big
deal back then um
so so talk a little bit about if you
will um
jay powell's first year in office
his first day in office for heaven's
sake the dow jones industrials fell more
than a thousand points and
and he said a lot of nothing and then
you know his first congressional
testimony he said you know it's not the
not the fed's job to backstop the stock
market
and and then we had paul
and then we had general electric debt
get downgraded halloween of that year
and then junk bond issuance froze for
41 days
all in the background he was
hoping that quantitative tightening
was like watching paint dry and all all
along in the background he was hoping to
get the fed funds rate
up to three percent
but something gay
in the financial system that didn't
allow him to achieve those goals what
was happening in the plumbing at that
time
that made it so increasingly difficult
for any form of normalization
yeah
so i think jake uh chair powell was
trying to hike rates saying no i think
he got all the way up to let's say
fourth quarter of 2018 and then he was
forecasting two more rate hikes in 2019
and you know i think the market just
kind of had enough and
as you suggested things kind of
fell apart and then i think the january
of 2019 they they kind of had to do a
180 and suddenly have to say you know
actually guys we're not going to hike
rates anymore we're going to cut rates
and so i think
what's happening is that there's is that
there's
when you hike rates
many things happen in the financial
system and one of them is one of the
things that is really important is that
the value of your fixed income
particularly things that people think of
as safe assets like treasuries they
decline in market value right
and charges are kind of like a type of
money in the financial system and when
you when as time goes on as you see the
jet that the gdp giant kind of explode
higher and higher
every red hike has a kind of a
disproportionate effect on the market
value of all this debt and so you have
people for example who um
maybe they're investors and they have a
60 40 portfolio and then they seeing
their treasury's portfolio kind of tim
declined in value then you know they
have to sell
to balance and equities and so forth so
in a sense when you hike rates
and the level of debt in the system is
really high you're kind of sucking out
market value kind of sucking out money
out of the system and when you have
leveraged players in the market and of
course people are always leveraged that
has a non-linear impact that kind of um
passes from point can really tip things
over and i think that's what happened
back in 2018 and will probably happen
again if we try to hack rates um let's
say
as aggressively as we did
uh
before
and it wasn't even that aggressive we'll
we'll get there i promise we'll get
there um
i'm curious about your views
about
um
kind of the reaction function of
of of the fed how it's become a
reactionary institute especially against
the backdrop of the introduction more
than a year ago now of average inflation
targeting the idea of letting inflation
run hot this was kind of
this was kind of a refutation if you
will of the taylor rule of any
disciplined approach rules-based
approach
to
to central banking um
how
jim grant used to always say he has
always said that the fed is both uh the
arsonist and the firefighter
so
should there be a different approach
at a high level when it comes to
monetary policy making that that is more
rules-based
so
you know the fed has an
inflation-targeting regime i've always
thought that was somewhat humorous
because i think one of the things that
you can clearly see
not just looking at the fed but in japan
and the ecb for example is that central
banks actually don't have the power to
create inflation um i mean they've been
trying for a long time they just don't
do it it's
so in that sense they're kind of in a
hard position where their task could do
something they actually can't do to
begin with
so
that's
that's one thing but having a
rules-based approach i think there are
benefits to it
the benefits obviously is that it's
transparent and that that people can
react to it and plan according to it and
i think that's pretty important in
markets being able to actually have an
understanding of what the fed's reaction
function is because if you don't
understand it and the fed does something
that surprises the markets you know you
could have some you know you could have
some blow ups and that that's not good
but the bad thing of course is is the
flexibility aspect when you have rules
then you know maybe you have that access
constraint and maybe you are bound to
them uh to some extent now um looking at
today for example we have an average
inflation targeting rule
but then you know just independent of
the fed outside of the box you have this
enormous fiscal stimulus that's pushing
up inflation right so what is how did if
you have a rigid you know inflation
targeting system even if it's average in
target inflation and yet you have this
fiscal authorities kind of our intent of
inflating with this fiscal policy then
you know it it'll force you to to kind
of maybe height rates more aggressively
than you otherwise would right so
um
so but if you hadn't if you didn't have
that rule then maybe you didn't have to
you wouldn't have to
do that so i think
i think it having rules there are good
things and bad things to it and the good
thing about the
inflation framework though is that
how you interpret averaging over what
period of time gives you a lot of leeway
to kind of you know
maybe wink a little bit
i think we're doing a lot of winking
right now with the whole idea of
transitory versus persistent so
absolutely absolutely
it was it's been it's like moving the
goalposts right but i actually kind of
think though that
well i like to think though that they
understand that maybe it might not be
transitory but the thing about central
bank communication though it's not
really telling you what they think
it's trying to shape the narrative right
a big part of fed communication is
trying to control inflation expectations
or rate expectations in general so one
of the fed's toolkits right post crisis
is something called forward guidance and
they'll say that you know what we're not
going to raise interest rates for the
next few years and that immediately has
an impact on how the market perceives
interest rates and you know maybe what
they're doing right now isn't saying
that inflation is you know not higher
just transitory maybe what they're doing
is trying to calm people down so they
won't out go out and panic by everything
right the messaging i think is is
actually is important in terms of
inflation if you think back to let's say
uh
1930s when roosevelt became president he
wanted to flight he's telling everyone
i'm going to inflate and i'm going to
you know devalue the dollar and people
saw that and they're like he's going to
inflate i better go buy stuff right now
and inflation skyrocketed maybe they're
doing the opposite right now i'm telling
you inflation is okay it's going to go
away so don't go out and panic by
um
or they could actually believe that it's
transitory
i'm happy you laughed after you said
that um
but so
the fed got into the business in a much
bigger way than it traditionally had of
buying
treasury inflation protected securities
yeah and that particular position got to
be
very sizable and i i think i think the
fed was trying to do what you you just
acknowledged
no is is the impossible is to create
this idea that can create
inflation so my question is at this
point
given
they would prefer that that the
inflation starts to
temper down why wouldn't they be selling
off their their their positions in these
treasury inflation protected securities
first of all can you explain what they
are just yeah
so
so tips are basically uh uh
they're securities that whose principal
adjusts with cpi so in the sense that
you're getting a real return rather than
just a nominal return and the way that
tips trade is that people take the
difference between let's say a 10-year
nominal treasury and a 10-year tips and
take that difference in mute yield and
just assume that's the market implied uh
inflation rate tips and plan inflation
rate
and um as you alluded to the fed kind of
bought a lot of tips in the past couple
years and that was pushing down the tips
real yields
um
pretty low and that was making market
implied inflation seem larger than than
i think what some people thought it
should be and there were some there was
some i think commentary that maybe the
fed is doing this to kind of make
inflation look larger um
i might have written something about
that a few times
you know i was on the desk back then and
there was actually some research by the
bis who just kind of came out and the
bis is like a respectable authority that
you know central banker services respect
and they're like you know i think that
chips and pine inflation is wider than
than in optimi because the fed is buying
all the steps
so i actually sent that around to all
the treasury colleagues and and i as far
as i know there's not some kind of
conspiracy to do that it was just
you know fed being the fed and bumbling
around but um
but uh yeah maybe there was some kind of
uh maybe someone someone did think that
way i was not aware of it but
but yeah that that did give the
impression that inflation was um i guess
higher than it than it uh otherwise
would be if the fed was not buying so
many tips couldn't they in theory
start to more aggressively temper back
their their position in that market
they could they could yeah so what the
the way that the fed does kiwi is that
they try to make it
um
they try to make their perpetrators in
proportion to the amount of treasuries
outstanding so for example if you know
10 percent of the just if 10 percent of
the treasury's market were tips 10
percent were 10 years then they would
try to
parse out their qe purchases in that say
so 10 approaches go to chips 10 percent
go to treasuries but you know that's
that's the theory and
and sometimes maybe things get lost in
the details
um
if you were to look at
say r squared first of all what is it
what what does
what do certain
rules and models at this juncture tell
us
uh
where you know in terms of where the fed
funds rate
should be
yeah so i think people look at this in
different ways right there's like the
you know shadow offended funds rate i
guess and things like that i'm myself
i'm not too big of a fan of these
economic models and that's part of the
reason why i like chirp pavo i mean i
remember when he first started he's you
know he's not an economist he's like
yeah these models are great but they're
kind of for reference only
so
when you think about
i think when you think about the economy
when i think about it at least i think
it's too complicated to be distilled
into just a mathematical equation and
definitely too complicated to be
distilled
to just for example rates as an input
like somehow you change the overnight
rate a little bit and you know magically
you know something happens you get
growth in inflation i think there's just
a lot of things that feed into
what determines inflation what
determines growth so having some kind of
you know
any kind of model that just kind of
says you know if you move
uh the overnight fed funds rate to
something that would that would give you
some kind of outcome i think it's
won't work and in fact it hasn't worked
for for some time right overly
simplistic case it's very very overly
simplistic and yeah it's just
i don't know maybe it's because the only
thing the fed can control is the
overnight interest rate market so that's
how they look at the world so you were
on the front lines and for whatever
reason things always seem to happen
right on my birthday september 17th but
you you were on the front line oh yeah
yeah 2019 you were right there
um you know repo rates spiked uh what on
earth
happened what created that moment
yeah i i was on the desk that that day i
was probably one of the first people
there and it was it was kind of an
exciting day so repo rates usually
are not very volatile right they're
supposed to basically be the same
rate more or less every day
and
just the week before you you know was
about two percent
and on that day um so that uh i can't
remember the exact day but just that
that two weeks into september i got to
my desk it was about seven a.m right
when the repo market opened up and like
within two minutes before i had even um
booted up my computer i got a call from
a dealer and he was telling me that
uh hey hey hey uh are you seeing this on
the screen um i've never seen anything
like this i think there's something
wrong with the repo market like okay you
know i better look into that
and so i you know i was entering my
bloomberg password to go in and then i
got another call i'm saying hey hey
look at the repo market something's
something strange is happening
so now i have to go look at it and i
just as i hung up um you know four more
people caught so the phones would ring
off the hook so repo rates back then
they basically doubled so they were like
two percent something out of the
previous session and then they were like
five and throughout that day they got as
high as maybe nine percent
and be a little bit higher and that's
not supposed to happen because
uh well repo normally is a very stable
market and more importantly as we
discussed earlier it's the plumbing of
the system you have basically a trillion
dollars worth of borrowing in the
overnight repo market every day and
people
rely expect that to be a be a very
stable market and if interest rates got
too high then they would have to deliver
and you know
as we mentioned before that creates um
just
selloffs and that can snowball
yeah cascades so that was it was it was
really not good to see the evil market
explode like that so
immediately i you know
i alerted everyone who could uh
could do something about this and you
know after a couple hours so actually
yeah a couple hours eventually the fed
came in that day and we started lending
in the repo market again which we
haven't done since uh
since the financial crisis and that that
was kind of a that was kind of a crazy
time because you don't expect ripple
mark they're basically exploding if you
look at a chart of sulfur and that's the
rate you look at it looks like they just
went vertical that day
what i think happened back then is that
you just kind of had this
it was basically a a squeeze in the
river market in the sense that it just
kind of ran out of money
so
the way that the rifle market works it's
a one-day loan right so people don't
actually have a lot of visibility as to
how much money is available so every
morning the dealers just you know call
their money fund contacts their cash
lenders and be like uh you know can you
i want to do i want to switch money and
so forth that's great and there's a
negotiation
there's there's not a lot of visibility
into how much money there is overall in
the market available
and all throughout the year 2019 if you
look at repo volumes
they were steadily climbing there's more
and more people borrowing and repo
i think a lot of it was
basically the cash futures basis trade
where people
try to arb the spread between cash
treasuries and futures and so that was
just that was just a growing a trade
that became very very popular and
there was um and you know like anything
else you keep growing you keep borrowing
and borrowing and borrowing and that's
all fine except that one day you show up
to the market and you need to borrow
because you have this let's say 10-year
treasury on your balance sheet that
you're rolling over every day that you
funded in repo and there's just not
enough money and what do you do but you
have to pay
at any price and so that's what happened
and what the reason why it ran out of
money is that just because that there
just wasn't enough
lender so the lenders at that time were
largely the commercial banks
and the commercial banks were lending uh
their reserves in the market
because they had a lot of extra reserves
and because reports were above interest
on reserves so they were doing that
i hate to interrupt and god they kill me
on youtube whenever i interrupt um but
but just just to clarify we're talking
about a
an ecosystem of broker dealers a finite
finance the broker dealers are yes
worker dealers are the borrowers in the
repo market so how this works is that
broker dealers borrow from cash lenders
in the ripple market they borrow for two
reasons one is to fund their own book of
securities the other is to
loan
pass the money on to their hedge fund
clients so basically uh it's like
they're borrowing overnight and then
letting for a two-week term too let's
say a hedge fund client who is uh who
also wants to uh who's who's also having
a leveraged position in treasuries so
that's that's how this works and so just
you know back to banking basics you have
repo loans which are rolled over
overnight kind of like a demand demand
deposit right at a bank and the bank has
loan assets but a real uh a repo dealer
a dealer has um surgeries that they
bought on their balance sheet or let's
say a two to three one three month loan
to a hedge fund client so both are at
least in the short term
not super liquid well the securities are
but you don't really want to sell that
because your whole business is to make
markets and securities
right and so once you lose the overnight
funding then you know you kind of have
to do something right and so
if it's just a disruption for one or two
days you can just really pay through the
nose and pay that five six seven eight
nine percent overnight that sounds like
a lot but you have to remember it's an
overnight loan so you have to divide
that by 360. so if you divide it you
know five percent by 360 it gets a very
small number
if that continues for a while then then
you have to do something on your asset
side so you have to either uh actually
sell some of your inventory security so
you won't have to borrow as much or you
have to
maybe not be able to lend as much to
your hedge fund clients so that's the
ecosystem for the dealers for the
borrowers on the lender's side it's
usually the money market funds but at
that point in time it was actually the
commercial banks so one of the things
that happened post qe is that the fed
massively increased the cash holdings of
the commercial banks and the commercial
banks have all this cash sitting on
their balance sheet that's earning
interest on reserves
and insurance fund reserves is great but
it would be even better if you can earn
a little bit higher than that right and
if you invest in an overnight repo loan
that's secured by treasury securities
you get the same regulatory treatment as
if you were just leaving it at the fed
and so
banks are basically let's say you know
making a few extra basis points
on these repo trades and at that time
the fed was also doing qt and so
even as it was so when you're doing qt
the fed is basically shrinking its
balance sheet and taking reserves out of
the system so
at that juncture in the repo market the
demand for repo borrowing was growing
so repo volumes are growing but the cash
lending side the amount of cash
available to lend to the ripple market
was shrinking because of qut and so you
just had hit that moment where um
demand grew grew supply and boom people
were paying at any price and everything
exploded
we also had currency in circulation
rising at a very fast rate at the same
time that negative interest rates in
other parts of the world had foreign
central banks parking money at the fed
as well because their countries were in
negative interest so and a good buddy of
mine george goncalves the way he
described it was that you know even as
powell was trying you know
to to push through with quantitative
tightening there were two other
uh there were two other factors that
equate it to the amount of liquidity
that was being pulled out of the system
via quantitative tightening at the same
time and he's raising interest rates so
there was there was just there was more
tightening going on than what even was
was in in the fed's control at the time
because of outside factors because there
were negative interest rates overseas
because people were piling into cash
physical cash
yeah yeah for sure um you know
definitely the physical cash holdings
have just been skyrocketing over the
past few years you know actually
incidentally i think most of that is
actually held abroad it's it's basically
how a lot of developing countries
or maybe people who are escaping the law
hold their hold their wealth it's true i
mean it's true but adults were a
reflection of you know anxiety if you
will
yes absolutely absolutely especially if
you're in a developing country for sure
so the fed steps in
yep um
in in on my birthday the fed steps in
and then
the fed has to continue to increase the
size
of
the we called it not qe at the time
because
these were these were technical
adjustments we were told
yeah so the fed had so the fed inside
the fed they were a little bit confused
that's what was going on because you
know they were telling everyone
everything was going to be okay and then
this happened and this is you know
ripple marketplace was not supposed to
happen so they weren't
really sure if it had something to do
with
quantitative tightening as in not enough
reserves in the system or if it was
something else maybe just repo dealer
there's a run in the repo market which
was kind of how i think about it
um so they did two things they started
lending into the repo market through the
open markets desk and they started doing
you know
buying treasury bills which is
increasing level of reserves in the
system so they did both just to be sure
um that this would not happen again and
yeah that that was that that seemed to
fix it repo rates
you know normalized and went back to
sleep again which um which which was
good so
uh what are
so yeah that they started buying those
treasury bills and those bills are
actually still on their balance sheet
too it's strange that they they still
happen there
rolled over
yes
you know but it it kind of felt like as
we were approaching the end of 2019 that
the market was looking for something
else that one to two year paper wasn't
exactly what the market had in mind that
maybe it was true qe
that uh
that they
that the market desired
uh in the old-fashioned way in a sense
um yeah i i like to think of or i i i
tell people that that towards the end of
2019 because
because things hadn't calmed down to the
to to a good enough extent that the fed
needed a black swan and i said it back
then
and
boy did they get a black swan
yeah yeah that was that was very much
surprise i think to to the fed and to
everyone i mean how many people heard
about repo before that right
so but we get this covid you know event
and
before we move on
uh
so
maybe tie the last discussion into the
standing repo facility that's just been
established
and back into the stress that was in the
system in 2019 and what the standing
repo facility can theoretically
do in the future not that we're thinking
about that right now because we're on
the opposite end of the spectrum but
just the same
so in the repo market the fed has two
facilities well
three but two main main ones but
be heading into
2019 and something we've had for a
number of years is the reverse report
facility which the fed stands to um
borrow in the review market for
basically unlimited amounts at a set
rate and that's to control repo rates so
they don't fall below a certain level
right
more recently they introduced something
called a standing repo facility which is
the fed leading into the repo market at
basically unlimited quantities at a set
rate
and the purpose of these two facilities
on the bottom and on the top is to
control repo rates so that they don't
they don't get out of the fed's uh
basically range
and
um in 2019 after the repo
you know roof market blow up in 2019 the
fed has basically been active
as a lender in the repo markets
so
even though technically there was no
standing repo facility they've basically
been actively lending every day in the
repo markets and especially after the
coveted pandemic every day at i would
say 1 15 p.m to 1 45 oh sorry 1 30 to 1
45 pm the fed is there willing to land
and
no one ever borrows them because there's
no need but the fed basically just
codified that codified that informal
practice with the standard ripple
facility such that these blow-ups can
basically never happen again because if
there was ever a time where the ripple
market
was losing control people can always go
to the fed and borrow unlimited
quantities
at the uh the fed's offering rates so
that's basically an extra rate control
tool that they have such that even if
they were to go to massive quantitative
tightening again and shrink the balance
sheet to like a tiny number uh the
ripple market wouldn't blow up because
you could always go to the fed standard
report facility and borrow unlimited
quantities from it in a sense it's kind
of like a discount window but instead of
for the banks it's for the dealers
so
in theory the fed has
one tool to make sure that they maintain
the floor
rates don't
bridge don't go into negative territory
and they have another tool that makes
sure that that rates don't go above a
ceiling so they can directly control the
range at which overnight
lending is done
overnight repo lending yeah you know
there's some talk that maybe so right
now the fed's official policy rate is
something called the fed funds rate with
an overnight unsecured rate
they also have this new reference rate
called sulfur which is their repo rate
and you know there's some talk that
maybe eventually one day the fed will
move from the fed funds rate so far as
their policy rate and if that's
something they'll do then they already
have the tools to control it so they can
make sure it doesn't go too low with the
reverse repo rate uh growth facility and
it doesn't go too high with the sending
repo facility like you mentioned
so uh
post pandemic uh obviously
the dearth of reserves problem
disappeared overnight with
three trillion dollars in counting of
just
correct me if i'm wrong weren't there
days that
that
i mean what was the biggest day of qe at
the very beginning
man so
march was just an amazing month in terms
of q i think the fed bought like a
trillion dollars in like three weeks so
just all the time there it was just
amazing like it's
i mean that's just mind-blowing the
numbers that
of kiwi that was being done there so
yeah that was
just unlike anything that the fed has
ever done before
yeah and and so uh
in in the background there's obviously
this masculine massive fiscal stimulus
the cares act and and
can you can you kind of explain what the
treasury general account is
uh because it it ended up at 1.8
trillion dollars
uh at one point and
in large part it's it's it's come back
into the discussion because now it's
being
depleted
yes so the treasury general account is
basically the fed's checking account at
the fed so
depending on who you are in the
financial system you hold different
types of money if you're like me and you
know just
normal retail people you hold money in
the form of checking account at a bank
but if you are a bank you actually hold
your money at a checking account at the
fed and the type of money you have is
called reserves
the treasury also has an account at the
fed it's called the tga and that's where
it keeps its
spare cash basically
now
in 2020 there was all this talk going on
that maybe the congress would do
additional stimulus and so forth right
and so the treasury wasn't actually sure
as to whether or not uh there would be
stimulus or how much money would be so
what it did though it's that it wanted
to be ready and so it
boiled a lot of money issued a lot of
treasury bills and took that money and
deposited it at the fed in its tga
account and you saw that account just
skyrocket to over a trillion like you
mentioned the highest it's ever been
um and so it was just kind of sitting
there waiting to to be spent waiting for
the stimulus to come but i don't think
the the expected stimulus actually came
so
um
so yeah that was not necessary but you
know no one knew at that time but right
now the tga account is being emptied and
it's uh you know 100 below 100 billion i
believe so it's been drawn it's been
dropped a lot
and the reason for that is has to do
with the debt ceiling so the way as we
all know the treasury has
the u.s government has a limit as to how
much debt it can hold right it can issue
and unless that that ceiling is lifted
it can't issue any more debt
so in order to stay above the debt
ceiling
the fed the treasury is basically paying
down some of its bills
using the tga account
and that gives it more room to maintain
its normal coupon issuance
so i'll just i'll step back a little bit
so treasury issues coupons which are
basically let's say longer term debt
that mature one year or more and they
issue bills which are shorter term debt
that matures within one year
the way that treasury likes to manage
itself is that it wants to keep its
coupon issuance pretty steady
and it wants to use
bills to manage its day-to-day cash uh
cash needs so when there are emergency
variables
yeah
exactly so when there are sudden
emergency needs for cash like in uh like
during the pandemic they issued a couple
trillion in bills without changing
coupon issues very much
and that's what those are for they can
but right now though they want to keep
their coupon issuance steady so
as they try to cut down on debt they're
cutting down on bills and so they're
paying down their bills with their tga
account so that's kind of going down
down down yep
but eventually when the that ceiling is
raised then that will go back up as
treasury can resume more bill issuance
well so
on the other side of that we continue to
see massive growth in the size of the
reverse repo
facility
treasury general account balance was
drawn down
uh so
at some point
if it's overnight and i i've asked this
question i think i've even asked this
question of you on twitter but at some
point if it's a trillion or 1.6 trillion
or heaven knows it might get up to two
trillion dollars by by the end of
december at some point if it's very
large amounts even though they're
overnight does it does it is it
tantamount to tightening
i don't think so no i don't think so um
i think the way to think about this is
just to think about it from an
investor's standpoint
so
if you're an investor right so
you can
you put your money um you can put your
money in a bank
or you can put your money in a money
market fund right uh just just assume
that
um
in that sense though that from your
perspective it doesn't really matter um
okay so
when you when when when people when the
money market though the people invest in
the rrp right
they are money market funds right and so
when they invest into the rrp what
they're doing to settle that transaction
so the banks have to the banks have to
lose reserves and send it to the fed so
in that sense the banking sector has
less liquidity because it has to settle
a transaction with the fed and so
reserves leave the bank's reserve
account and go to the fed's rep facility
so in that sense it reduces the amount
of liquidity held in the baking sector
so that's that's for the perspective of
the banks
but from the perspective of let's say
investors though uh there's there's
really no difference and basically
instead of holding uh you yeah i mean
basically you still hold a money market
front share or you still hold a bank
deposit it doesn't really change
anything from your perspective
but it could slightly reduce the amount
of liquidity in the banking sector
but
the thing is though it's actually banks
actually like that so
one of the restrictions upon banks post
crisis is something called a
leverage ratio and a supplementary
leverage ratio and that means a bank can
only have so much
it can only get so big it sounds strange
but
banks can actually you know
have
too much too much assets too much money
so
when when you do qe you actually stuff
the banks with so much liquidity that it
pushes against the regulatory ratios so
that they can't get any bigger
and
one of the ways that they can actually
get have some relief from this is if
they push money out of their bank
into let's say money market fund who
then invests in the rp and shrinks the
of our bank's balance sheet so it's it's
actually a helpful thing for the
financial system
um
let's let's take this one step further
because uh
there have been some papers written some
white papers written
um the g30
put a paper out recently that walked
through
many steps that the fed could take
to ensure that
what happened in march of 2020 was never
able to recur again i'm i'm sure you
were there when in in overnight trading
in asia you couldn't trade the long bond
um so it was a highly unusual
circumstance uh but but the g30 has has
has started to uh
has not started to the
the g30 came out with a paper endorsing
uh the idea of something called swing
pricing
and the idea of
we know that in march of 2020 that when
the stock market would fall by a certain
percentage point that circuit breakers
would kick in
and trading would be halted
there's an idea that
the fed could actually come in and
implement the same type of mechanism but
in the bond market itself and i'm
talking about the corporate bond market
uh what are your thoughts on that
yeah that i i don't yeah i'm not i'm not
too sure i haven't really thought about
that that
i think it's good to have a price for
liquidity and but uh
yeah i know i'm not too sure about that
no i haven't thought about that much
we're gonna have to come back and talk
about that then
um but the same g30 paper also addressed
the issue of the central clearing of
treasuries
yes
and the idea that uh that the
broker-dealer community being
as
as as small of a cohort
as it is
uh
that that that universe be broadened out
and that their and that treasuries are
centrally cleared maybe you can walk me
through
what percentage of the market is cleared
in the dealer community and what central
clearing of treasuries would actually
would actually do because again
you know you're talking about the fed
trying to
with its standing repo facility and it's
reverse repo facility trying to
make sure that it controls the ceiling
and and the floor in in the repo market
this would be something that ensured
liquidity in the entire treasury market
yeah so the treasury market is you know
broadly broken up into like an
inter-dealer market or dealers trade
with each other
in a dealer to client market where
dealers trade to trade with let's say an
investment fund wants to buy a surgery
then they would call up their dealer and
be like hey i would like to buy a
10-year on the run can you sell it to me
and they would give a quote
um so the inter-dealer market is is
cleared but the the market for dealer
the customer is not cleared and what
that means is if you have a cleared
market then eventually at the end of the
day all the trades face the
clearinghouse so that helps you save on
counter that's you control cotton party
risk but it also allows you to net your
transactions so it allows you to save on
balance sheets so let's say you know if
if iodik's send your card reported this
much money and someone else and it owes
me the same amount of money then that
net sell right otherwise it'd have to be
a gross transaction
and that takes a balance sheet and one
of the impetuses for for essential
clearing is that um there's a thought
that back
during march
that one of the reasons why there was
there was trouble so just to sit back so
what happened during march was that the
dealers basically um were not able to
make markets in treasury treasury
securities and that was very strange
because usually we think of treasuries
as the deepest most liquid market in the
world you're supposed to be able to sell
treasuries instantly um but back then
that was impossible and that was
tremendously distressing because
treasuries are basically like a form of
money in the financial system and
calling up your dealer and not being
able to sell your treasuries it's just
like going to the bank and sitting in
the bank telling you sorry you can't
withdraw anything so that that is all
sorts of distressing
and there are many reasons for why that
didn't happen back that that happened
back then but one of the reasons people
thought was perhaps the dealers did not
have enough balance sheet space
so they basically everyone was selling
the securities and they were not able to
hold any more so they couldn't make
markets and one of the ways that you can
potentially give more balance sheet
space to dealers though is if you had
centrally killer treasuries because in
the payments then everyone would be
facing the central clearinghouse and
that would
give them more space under the under the
regulations
so they could net their net their
payments and so they would have more
space to hold more treasuries and i
think that's that's i mean not obviously
having more having essentially cleaning
houses is good for managing risk and
it's good for saving balance sheets so i
think that's a really good thing um if
whether or not would have helped back
then i i don't know um one of the things
that i think we've come to learn is that
it's not so much that there was not
enough
balance sheet space as to when there's a
lot of volatility you just kind of
dealers just don't want to make markets
because you could buy something the
price can move a lot then you could end
up losing money so it's just kind of
prudent risk management
so you know let's say you buy something
for seven dollars you want to sell it
for ten dollars right but if the price
is fluctuating a lot maybe you buy
something for seven dollars and you can
only sell it for six and you lose money
so um i think when you have really
volatile pricing
it's just more difficult to make markets
and maybe having centric coloring would
have helped then but
i think it was
probably not the only thing that
mattered well what would the
implications be
in terms of profit profitability for the
primary dealer
community if if we were to have such a
central clearing
of treasuries
well central cooling usually makes
markets i guess more efficient so that
makes the spreads narrower or maybe
makes it less profitable so
same time it also makes it less costly
right and less risky so it's
but if you look at the overall trend in
the markets i mean let's say interest
rate swaps for example they're all
centrally cleared now
um
and
uh so
i think that's the trend towards all
markets and it's just
uh i think for maybe it makes trades
less profitable for banks and dealers
but
overall it does make the financial
system safer so it's not necessarily a
bad thing
um so i've got a i've got a question or
two that's come in from randy woodward
here
i love brownies andy's amazing he's a
great client um
so in your book central banking 101 you
referred to the to the central making
community as a surprisingly tight-knit
group you're going to describe how many
of the central banks european central
bank bank of england and especially the
bank of japan not only have regular
meetings but send staff to work on the
new york fed's trading desk for periods
of time
how do you think that affects policy
between
central banks and do you feel one has
more influence over the others or does
it ebb and flow but most importantly do
you think actions by one bank namely the
bank of japan can predict where the
other central banks will head if need be
specifically do you think the fed will
buy equity
exchange traded funds
if they feel it's necessary that was a
big question
yeah japan does seem to seem to be the
leader in the
in central banking policy right they did
qe in size before anyone did buying all
sorts of assets before anyone did
so
i think
one thing to keep in mind is that
the central banking community at least
in the western world in advanced
countries
they all kind of have similar
structures in their economy similar you
know western democratic framework they
also have people who went to the same
schools right so i mean uh for example
mario draghi went to mit and you know as
did many other very prominent fed people
so they they think of the world in in a
similar way so that's part of the reason
why there's kind of a policy convergence
fed has these
so
so during the last pandemic the fed
bought
you know corporate debt right and maybe
a little bit of junk and not a lot
overall i think they bought maybe 12 13
billion
it was nominal but but it worked wonders
people saw that and just i think the
bond market went on fire just
well i mean it was 10 trillion dollars
on february the 19th outstanding i for
whatever remember february the 19th i
saw an article that said the u.s bond
market has just passed the 10 trillion
milestone now it's pushing 11.5
yeah everyone wants wants to buy what
the fed is buying right i can't lose
sell that so they thought so i think you
could ask someone 10 years ago whether
or not the fed would buy
you know junk bonds it would be no right
so
when i was inside the fed we had that
debate and the answer was
absolutely not we talked about municipal
bonds the answer was absolutely not and
there was a big old debate about even
mortgage-backed securities back then
that was even seen as credit easing and
trying to
alleviate one particular sector of the
economy which is a no no it well it was
a no no at the fed
so the fed has done things that no one
thought would could do before
and i think people would like to say
that's not legal or something like that
but i i don't actually think that's the
right standard when you
talk about government because the
government kind of makes the rules and
so there really is no
law that binds them they could always
find a loophole in a way in this case
they basically had treasury put down
equity and then basically lend to that
so they had a special investment vehicle
had treasury put up equity as a first
loss then lent to that church special
investment vehicle and that special
investment vehicle bought
bought let's say credit assets and so
they could easily do the same for
equities
and
you know i have
no doubt that if the smart market
crashed tremendously that they would do
something like that it's it's just that
the stock market is so systemically
important
um it's where basically the vast
majority of people you know put their
retirement savings and including people
at the fed right i'm sure many many
fed officials wake up every day and log
into their retirement account and look
forward to that day when they can retire
and they don't like they don't like it
when they wake up and see it down 20 30
percent so there is some self-interest
there and that's involved
i mean if you look across the advanced
economies
like benny mentioned the bank of japan
has been buying equities swiss national
bank as well
buys a lot of u.s equities actually
so
um i think that we are very much firmly
on the trend towards the fed one day
buying equities
just uh maybe a crisis away
would that be
would that be the right thing to do
i mean there was the the
there was a treasury
treasury fed a court of 1951
after world war ii to to divorce the the
fed from the treasury and make sure that
the fed was an independent a political
entity uh as required by the federal
reserve act of 1913.
i think that's that's no i think that's
how it should be and i think that it's
good to have an independent central bank
but we don't always have an independent
central bank um if you remember
uh
i think one of the
so i was um i remember reading this
quote by richard nixon back then when
his chairman arthur burns was being
nominated and i remember him saying that
i or something to the extent that you
know i hope you do policy independently
but i hope that you independently come
to the conclusion that
my view is the best or something like
that
so
um so i think central bank independence
is something that varies throughout time
and
um
maybe we are moving towards a world
where
where um we have less of that i think
it's it's not good that we have less of
that we should have more central bank
independence
but
i think one of the things that happens
is that if you have a essential if you
have a central bank that is
um
very accommodative then you
kind of
well in a sense you have your inflation
in your
in your in your goals you have to react
to what's what's what the other side of
the government is doing what the fiscal
policies are doing and so that kind of
constrains you a bit
so let's say that the fiscal government
wants to do
something that wants to stimulate the
economy and you know
has a goal of just significantly
significantly raising wages and reducing
unemployment and one of the side effects
of that is higher inflation
i think it's very difficult for a
century bank to go against that and try
to raise rates
and for example to reduce inflation
even though that might come at the cost
of the
of congress's goal of just raising wages
and
reducing unemployment so it's a
difficult spot to be in and in that case
i think that
you know i think you're very you're very
much speaking to where we are today yeah
i think it's literally describing where
we are at this i mean we're at this very
moment
and it's
unrealistic to expect that i think the
fed to buck the congressional intent
so
um
maybe maybe our stronger more
independent fed would but i don't know
if that's that's where we are now so um
let's just say that uh well and actually
on a fundamental level let let's just
imagine a world
in which there was no dual mandate to
begin with
um
can you can you explain kind of
as if i was a five-year-old
why the employment mandate naturally
conflicts with the inflation mandate
yeah so
i mean
so let's say where we are right now we
have
high inflation
um so
usually people think of and
so there's
traditionally there's this thought of
the phillips curve right when you have a
relationship between employment
and inflation
and so um when you have
high inflation you usually have
um you usually have low unemployment
right because you have the economy
heating and so
there's more jobs wages go up inflation
goes higher right so high inflation and
low unemployment
in the same way if you have high
unemployment usually there's low
inflation because there's a lot of slack
in the in the economy right so there's
not a people a lot of people with jobs
there's not a lot of demand and so
inflation is low
um so there's kind of this push and pull
here where when if you want to have very
low unemployment
usually that means there's a lot of
inflation because that means there's a
lot of demand in economy right
and
right now we're at a moment where we
kind of have pretty high inflation and
also
what
pretty high unemployment so we're at
this juncture where the fed kind of has
to choose between these two mandates if
it was focusing on inflation then it
would raise rates right but if you raise
rates you have this trade-off where you
kind of slow down the economy and then
your unemployment rate increases
um
if for example you wanted to focus on
your mandate of
employment full employment then you
would want to run the economy
hotter or at least to the level where
you thought fluent full employment was
and so you would leave rates lower
encourage the economy to grow and so
what happens then is that inflation
rises
above your target
um while you try to achieve the
unemployment target so in the sense that
these are in conflict and it's very
difficult to resolve them and the fed is
at a juncture here would have to choose
what's more important inflation or
unemployment
so that's that's one end of the
philosophical spectrum because i've
always been a i'm gonna i wrote it in my
book i've always been an advocate of of
getting rid of the employment mandate
and leaving that to the private sector
which allows the fed to be in my view
much more independent in nature
so
at the opposite end of that
philosophical spectrum lies central bank
digital currency
and
i'm curious what your your views are
about the idea of
kind of the eradication of cash
everybody having a a a checking account
directly at the federal reserve this is
kind of lacy hunt's
nuclear option of making the fed's
liabilities into legal tender
what are your thoughts on cbdc because
it is a very hot topic right now
when i first heard about cbdc for the us
i had no idea why we would need
something like that and
um you know i
was thinking that i was crazy when i
heard randall quarles basically say
something similar a couple weeks ago so
when i think from my perspective i keep
money at a bank it's insured by the fdic
i'm never worried that it will disappear
when i make transactions is with my
credit card it's instant and digital and
you know it works very well for me so i
have no idea why i would use a cbdc and
if you talk about maybe banking the
unbanked well you know you in the us you
go around every corner there's a bank
that wants to give you a free checking
account and a cup of coffee
i'm sure that the fed will not be able
to offer you the same services
when i think about cbdc
i wasn't sure about what it was about
until i began to see what was happening
with the nomination of the comptroller
of the currency
um rova right so the biden nominee
actually wrote a paper about the control
controller of the currency is one of the
nation's top bank regulatory posts
and the nominee for that has written
papers on cbdc's and and banking and her
views are that
the entire banking sector should be
socialized everyone should have an
account at the central bank and the
central bank should decide
directly or indirectly who gets loans
it's basically uh
you know
soviet or soviet system basically just
you know or actually indirectly uh
chinese system as well basically the
government decides you keep all your
money with the government and the
government decides who gets loans it's
the complete opposite of
our free market system
so
the only way that cbd's make sense i
think is in the context of that plan and
it does seem like that there's an effort
to move towards that plan so um i hope
that doesn't happen i think that is not
a good direction for our economy no
if the
i don't think cbds make sense for us
unless that's the that's the uh banking
model that
the
some people want to move us to
well um i'm happy that you're pulling
with me to fight this and i i really do
think that this
is at the very core of the
the
the discord between lael brainerd and
jay pal because if you think of an
omarosa brainerd team that would be the
dream team for universal basic income uh
effectively and and implementing a cbdc
so uh so
there was so if you think about the
pandemic there was kind of a
test for that right but this time it was
done through the baking sector so
basically the treasury
passed out a whole bunch of checks
everyone and the fed funded it through
its massive qb so it was basically the
uh you know basic income but it was done
through the baking sector
a cbdc would allow them to just kind of
bypass this whole banking sector thing
and just send money directly
to people and and boy would we have
inflation
i think it's happening as we speak well
that's
i i tell people that we've taken
universal basic income on a test drive
and we've seen what the result is since
it's more inflation than we've seen in
our lifetimes so
um
so there's a lot of talk right now about
policy errors
and before we get to where we are today
and and wind up our discussion i'm
curious do you think do you think lehman
was a policy er
yes actually i do um because it kind of
brought down the entire financial system
right so okay
and i would have that
it's a rhetorical question to you and me
that's good news but
there's a lot of debate that surrounds
it so
no no it's good that i mean
we should have saved lehman because
i mean that really destroyed the
financial system weak
lehman was too big to fail and that
if we saved lehman there would not been
no great financial crisis and i think
that would have saved a lot of
destruction to the real economy and to
the financial economy into like a
so
here when i was a lawyer actually one of
the cases i worked on was um on the
lehman brothers bankruptcy
and
uh
i worked at a firm that represented the
unsecured creditors for the lehman
brothers and we would get letters just
from ordinary people who who would send
who were creditors who put their money
with lehman best and lehman saying that
i lost everything you know please help
me get my money back so that was that
was there were a lot of real people and
who who got hurt there and that would
not have happened if we say believement
i um i i happen to wholeheartedly agree
um
let's let's end this discussion and
promise to come back and revisit all of
these subjects
um with the question of
what should the fed do
what can the fed do honestly i i i don't
think that i don't think the fed can do
i think the fed is trapped and that's
just so this is how i think about it
right
so
you have inflation that's driven because
the fiscal authorities are giving people
a lot of money and there may be some
supply constraints as well
if you raise rates
that's not actually going to work that
well in the contemporary banking system
and there's some structural reasons for
that but one of them is that if you were
to raise rates
it doesn't actually tampen down on
demand because none of that feeds
through to to to normal people
usually what happens when you raise
rates it works in two ways one is that
it restricts the supply of credit by
making it more expensive for a bank to
make loans so if a bank is borrowing in
money markets to fund its loans then
when the fed raises its interest rates
then the cost of funds increases and
then the bank is more reluctant to make
loans because it's less profitable
unless it marks up
um
what we're happening right now post qe
is that the bank system is awash in
deposits so there's not a lot of
uh and banks don't really use money
market funding anyway right from a
regulation standpoint it's too costly
so
that's not going to decrease the
increase the costs of funding for banks
and from another so that channel won't
work the other channel is that it makes
it creates an opportunity cost for
consumers whereas let's say um
money market rates are one percent maybe
i'm less inclined to spend that money
but by that same channel that i
mentioned before the bank is not going
to raise the interest it's offering to
its checking accounts because it has so
many deposits in the banking system
after kiwi
so even if the fed raised their interest
rates by one or two hundred percent it's
really not going to feed into the world
economy
through those two channels so that's not
going to work a lot
but what it will do though i think it is
will severely damage financial assets
and that could
end up
creating some kind of cascade like we
saw in 2018
and so
you can't really fine-tune this
that much it's either a little that does
nothing or a lot that just kind of
destroys financial markets so it's a
difficult place to be in
but you know if you also think of it
from a political standpoint
i think the fed is changing this
conversation and maybe
um you know we have a more left-leaning
fed chair possibly i i don't know
um and that they could just choose from
an economy hotter basically between
their two mandates choose employment
over inflation as being more important
but um the fed isn't i think it's in a
hard hard hard spot right now there's
really no good
no good um
solutions
i i happen to agree with you and we're
about to find out
uh we're about to find out what tapering
feels like and whether or not the
market's just going to shrug it off or
not it's going to be okay though because
one of the things that i think that
people don't really realize is that so
tapering has
the effect of tapering has to do with
treasury issuance as well right so if
the fed is buying 10 billion
bonds
a month that effect is going to be
different depending on whether treasury
is issuing 100 billion a month or just
one billion a month right so even as the
fed tapers in the coming months the
treasury will also cut issuance
significantly right so
net on that there's not going to be too
much of additional supply
uh
into the market
well i mean
the decreasing in um
the tapering will not cause incremental
supply because treasure will be cutting
it i think it's issues
exactly november third is happens to be
the same day that treasury's supposed to
make its refunding announcement exactly
and that's when we'll find out two
things on one day okay um
what we've covered a lot and i know this
this is this is really difficult
material for a lot of people to
understand and i can't thank you enough
because
you do the best job out there
at putting it into as plain of english
as as anybody has and and that's
something that's really important
because
well as long as the plumbing's working
it's fine but um but if you're in a
house when the plumbing's not working
you're getting out of the house so i
thank you so much for your time and uh
and i look forward to visiting again
my pleasure danielle i really enjoy your
show and thank you for inviting me love
to come back thank you take care
thanks
so that was super wonky i know um but
but if you listen to what joseph wang
had to say
when things do go wrong in the plumbing
of the financial system the ripple
effects throughout the rest of the
economy and the world economy for that
matter
are are absolutely critical to
understand so if you have to go back and
watch it twice
go for it and i do hope that you enjoyed
his views if you want to see a different
perspective from somebody who's also
another expert in the the financial in
the financial plumbing of the system
check out the interview that i did a few
months back with george goncalves and he
also provides great perspective into
this arcane world that again is so
critically important for investors to
understand i do hope you enjoyed this
episode subscribe to the channel if you
have not yet and i look forward to the
next time this is danielle demartino
booth with down the middle
[Music]